une page cinéma peut-être du nouveau sur
l'assassinat du président Kennedy ce
n'est pas le titre d'une dépêche mais le
sujet du dernier film d'Henry Verneuil i
comica avec Yve Montan film qui sera sur
les écrans français mercredi prochain
spécialiste du film de divertissement et
du policier Henri Verneuil nous donne
aussi cette fois à réfléchir un
reportage de
George 63 % de la population du globe
est capable de donner la mort à
quelqu'un qui ne lui a rien fait par
simple soumission à l'ut supérieure
telle était la conclusion d'un rapport
du professeur américain Stanley Milgram
après 3 ans d'expérience Henry Verneuil
profondément ému et choqué par cette
constatation a voulu en faire un film
mais Henry Verneuil est un cinéaste qui
aime le spectacle et son incursion dans
le monde de la psychanalyse et de
l'expérience scientifique ne l'a pas
conduit vers le documentaire I comicar
est un film à deux visage d'un côté une
enquête
policière devant un meurtre et quel
meurtre c'est la mort d' d'un président
et puis à un moment donné cette enquête
débouche sur une réflexion et cette
réflexion c'est la soumission à
l'autorité dites monsieur on pourra
peut-être passer au mot suivant pour une
fois il est absolument essentiel que
nous poursuivions l'expérience monsieur
Despo bah oui mais il ne répond plus
vous devriz aller voir il lu peut-être
arrivé quelque chose que ce la plaise ou
non à l'élève nous devons continuer
jusqu'à ce que l'élève sache
correctement les couples de mots dans
l'histoire de humanité on a tué beaucoup
plus de gens par obéissance que par
toutes les rébellions et toutes les
révolutions réunies quand vous prenez
300000 étudiants amassés devant une
ambassade et des otages de l'autre côté
soumission à l'autorité cette autorité
étant une autorité religieuse à l'autre
bout du monde vous prenez des gens qui
ont un fusil et qui tirent sousmission à
une
idéologie c'est intolérable même au nom
de la science n'z pas le droit de faire
ça aucune loi
votre calme Monsieur le Procureur n
sommes depuis des mois nous vivons à
l'ombre d'un faux d'El mais tout est
faux dans cette affaire tout un faux
témoin un faux coupable de fausse
douille de faussees date et de faus
hortenia et un faux rapport avec un
fauxon y montant joue le rôle d'un
procureur intègre qui refuse les
conclusions du rapport sur le meurtre du
président de son pays il reprend
l'enquête à zéro pourquoi Carl er dasel
aurait tiré sur le président alors qu'il
est établi qu' n'avait pas la moindre
raison de le faire la recherche de la
vérité coûte très cher quelquefois mais
je pense P que c'est dans l'homme je
pense que quand on a la possibilité de
rechercher cette vérité je pense que
quel que soit votre position dans la vie
et si vous avez la possibilité de le
faire je pense qu'il faut la mener à
bien et qu'il faut essayer en tout cas
quel que soit les risques sinon il y a
pas de vie possible je crois vous avez
participé à beaucoup de films plein de
bonnes intentions
humanitaire là
au-delà des attentions de l'auteur il y
a un spectacle est-ce que c'est ce qui
vous a séduit dans le côté Verneuil oui
parce que je pense que précisément ce
genre de problème traités ils doivent
être avant tout
spectaculaires je pense que s'il n'y a
pas le spectacle s'il n'y a pas le côté
spectacle vraiment spectacle il est
difficile de faire d'ouvrir certaines
portes qui qu' on veut garder
volontairement fermé c'est pas du tout
pour faire humanitaire à tout prix je
suis comme tout le monde aussi je donne
aussi mes coups de pieds dans le petit B
comme tout le monde je suis agressif
comme tout le monde et je suis aussi
cruel comme tout le monde parce que nous
sommes comme ça je crois que les gens on
essayer de leur ouvrir les yeux je pense
qu'ils veulent les garder fermux parce
que c'est d'abord beaucoup plus
sécurisant et puis aussi pour garder une
certaine chaleur et puis parce qu'ils ne
veulent pas voir la réalité en face et
que ça les gêne la réalité que ça les
affaiblit et que je m'associ à tous ces
gensl attention je ne suis pas
l'exception naturellement et je pense
que
ils ont peur de voir la réalité t
qu'elle est
vraiment et je pense que quand on a la
possibilité précisément de démontrer
certaines choses je pense qu'il faut le
faire vous avez peur monsieur vous avez
raison d'avoir peur vous ne le savez
peut-être pas mais il y a eu personnes
qui comme vous ont vu quelque chose le
jour o le président a été assassinéors
ça tombe très bien adressev au li de
m'emmerder ça me sera difficile voyezv
ces h personnes sont mortes je précise
pas de mort naturelle si vous refusez de
vous confier à moi vous serez le 9e pas
le 9e témoin le 9e cadavre évidemment
vous êtes un parfait Sal et bien il faut
choisir monsieur le parfait salot ou le
tueurar est déjà sorti sur les écran
parisien et dans de nombreuses villes de
province